he inherited mrs. Mays appalling
surrender treaty and he did it with the
clock running down to the 31st of
October I don't doubt for a moment that
he tried his best to improve it and
perhaps the one significant achievement
was that Great Britain is not committed
to being in the customs union but the
price of that was appalling
new Barker has more from London the
brexit Party was formed in January this
year by Nigel Faraj the former leader of
the UK Independence Party Nigel Farage
has been at the center of brexit
politics for many years now he's been a
thorn in the side of multiple prime
ministers and essentially goaded the
former Prime Minister David Cameron into
holding the referendum in the first
place
the brexit party did very very well
earlier this year in European
parliamentary elections winning more
seats than all of the established
political parties but Faraj knows
there's a big difference between a
European parliamentary election and a
general election which is why he's come
up with a plan he's asked Boris Johnson
to scrap his withdrawal agreement to
leave the European Union if he doesn't
he says that the brexit party will put
forward candidates in every seat in the
country the logic is that if Johnson
agrees to this then the brexit vote
won't be divided between the brexit
party and the Conservatives and Boris
Johnson can hold on to his hopes of
getting a majority in parliament
Faraj is calling for a non-aggression
pact asking for the Conservatives not to
stand in a hundred and fifty seats
around the country where the
Conservatives have never won because
Faraj believes his party can win those
seats especially places where the
opposition Labour Party is now in
control places where the majority of
people in those constituencies voted to
leave the EU or Johnson's be given until
November the 14th to consider this
possible arrangement with the brexit
party johnson has ruled out in the past
any possible pact between Farraj and
himself johnson is very confident that
his party
can win a majority but he can't afford
to be complacent his deadline of October
the 31st for leaving the EU has now been
and gone there's a lot of anger and
frustration amongst Euroskeptics and
ardent brexit supporters who may decide
to punish Boris Johnson when they go to
the polls in December well more on this
we can speak to Johnathan list who's the
deputy director of the think-tank
British influence a pro Europe
think-tank and a business advisory group
and he joins us now live from London
Jonathan I want to start by taking stock
because it's now the 1st of November and
Britain is still very much a part of the
European Union surprised not at all
surprised anyone who followed EU and UK
politics for the last couple months
should have known that Boris Johnson had
very little chance of getting a deal
through by the 31st of October and even
last week Boris Johnson was insisting
that this deadline would be met it's
clear that it couldn't be met and that
makes Johnson look both dishonest and
weak well we've now had two British
Prime Minister's lose their jobs
essentially because of brexit so Cameron
may now potentially Johnson so heading
towards the selection what is going
through Boris Johnson's head do you
think how confident is he I think that
Boris Johnson is defined by his
confidence and that's why he was
determined that we would leave that on
the 31st October
even though Parliament was saying we
wouldn't sorry I think confidence is he
issue for him I think that the real
problem he has is that he has broken
this cardinal pledge he made to leave
the EU by the 31st of October he is also
angered people who are in favor of No
Deal by nailing his flag to the mast of
a deal and of course he's infuriated the
unionists in Northern Ireland and
Ellsbury in the UK by agreeing a treaty
which puts a border in the Irish Sea and
that's when Nigel Faraj comes in because
he knows that the only chance he has is
to try and claim those voters who are
now disillusioned with Boris Johnson but
how successful he is will determine the
whole election also given all of that
how United are the big parties here
because this election is for British
leadership but it won't necessary
resolve all the the big brexit questions
talk us through the options for voters
here so I think that brac state posed a
problem for all the parties and that is
why the Labour Party in particular we
want to talk about issues way beyond
brexit so we're going to hear a lot
about the rigged electrode the rigs are
sort of a financial system for example
we're going to hear about the failures
of capitalism we're going to hear a lot
about the NHS and the Conservatives will
also try and make a big claim about the
NHS and their spending commitments while
the Liberal Democrats will try and claim
the territory of stopping brexit by
being the revoke party so what we may
well see in this election which is the
most unpredictable in 30 years is that
the remain vote will split between
labour and the Liberal Democrats and
many seats which could hand seats the
Conservative Party and the proper exit
vote or split between the Conservatives
and the brexit party which could
actually hand seats to labour all the
Liberal Democrats so we simply don't
know what's going to happen but as
things stand
the Conservatives look set to be the
biggest party even if they don't get a
majority Jonathan just taking a bit of a
step back it's now been nearly three and
a half years since that first referendum
and you're in London how is the country
feeling now divided certainly frustrated
presumably asking some pretty big
existential questions I think Britain is
completely divided and it shows no signs
of changing the countries that have been
battered politically socially for the
last three and a half years now and so
there's a sense of exhaustion that we
simply don't know how to make this stop
and we don't know how to make things
better and that's really what the
parties are all going for the Liberal
Democrats and labour offering a route to
stop this by having a referendum the
Conservatives are saying we need to get
brexit done but the problem with that is
the brexit is not going to get done if
we do leave the EU that's number X that
gets begun because that's when the
negotiations begin and the parties are
simply not being honest about that at
the moment Jonathan lists there the
deputy director of the think-tank
British influence thank you for joining
us on al-jazeera Jonathan